[FELICE FRANKEL speaking]
In this week's
discussion of video,
we're going to show you
some interesting examples
of other peoples' work.
Now, remember that
the basics of still
photography that
you've just learned
all these previous weeks, apply
to making successful videos.
For starters, we are
incredibly lucky to be
able to show you some remarkable
videos from a project called
"Beautiful Chemistry".
Here's the website
with full credit.
Now I encourage you
to see them all.
I am quite sure they
will inspire you come up
with your own amazing
videos, if your work requires
video capturing
macro-level phenomena.
Scientist Yan Liang, a
collaborator of mine,
is the creator and
director of the project.
We asked him to tell us a
little about his techniques
for three of the videos.
Welcome, Liang, to our class.
[YAN LIANG speaking]
Thank you, Felice.
It's wonderful being
part of this course.
I'd be happy to talk
about how we captured
three particular phenomena.
In this segment we're showing
metal displacement reactions.
We dropped zinc metal
into different solutions
and recorded the emergence
of beautiful structures
of other metals such
as silver or lead.
All reactions were
shot in real time
and we sped them up during
editing in Final Cut Pro X.
For example, one sort
of silver displacement
was sped up 60 times, which
means one second of our video
is one minute in real time.
For light setup, we used
two large LED panels
to light a cubic glass
container in which
the reactions occurred.
Typically, a black cloth
or a white plastic board
was placed about one
foot behind the container
as black or white background.
And we shot reactions
in the front
with a Panasonic GH4 camera
and 100mm macro lens.
All the reactions were
shot in a normal lab
with overhead
fluorescent lights.
Because the LED panels
were so much brighter
than the fluorescent lights,
we typically left them on.
In this segment, we are
showing a few crystallization
processes, including
crystallization
of copper sulfate, sodium
thiosulfate crystallization,
and two more.
We chose crystallization
processes
that are fast enough so that
we could shot in real time
and speed them up in editing.
We did not select
crystallization processes
that could take hours or
days to form large crystals.
For those, time-lapse
photography has to be used,
and lighting and exposure have
to be carefully controlled
to avoid flicker
in the final video.
Finally, in this segment, we
are showing a few bubbling
reactions, such as zinc metal
reacts with hydrochloride acid
to form hydrogen bubbles.
These reactions are
fast and we usually
did not need to speed
them up in editing.
Our light setup worked
well for bubbles.
The white highlights on
the right and left sides
of the bubbles are the
reflection of two light panels.
These highlights gave bubbles
a very interesting look.